i think i need a second put it in that
filter i think i need more
sorry one second you still need more i
swear i lift weights slow poke let's go
so i promise i'm grinding this did i
like change a setting or something
hey sue it's good to see you on this
coffee havoc
facebook group hey how's it going good
i can't believe you're here man i'm
fangirling out listen
i need to learn how to make coffee so we
all have things in life we need to get
better at you know what i'm saying
that's awesome the truth is it's my
fiance who is the coffee maker in the
house
she's teased me a time or two about the
pot that i make
so this is perfect i need to get better
and i need to
put that right in her face if you know
what i'm saying when did you first start
making coffee
i got into coffee kind of late-ish it
was probably like my mid-20s where
i was a full go like every morning i
drink a cup of coffee
probably like two to three hours before
every game it gives me that uh caffeine
boost we all need
usually it's in the morning for me it's
it's later in the afternoon on a game
day
we're gonna start turning on that hot
water and grab your
beans this coffee straight from seattle
i think we're off to a good start here
this smells delicious
fill that bad boy up doing a great job
steve
thanks i'm good with directions it's the
athlete in me
go ahead and start grinding that up this
is the hard part
the 2020 wnba season we were
in a bubble which we affectionately
called the wubble we were there for
three months and megan was with me
and in order to make it more like homey
we actually went and got
a grinder kettle you know that was our
thing we're gonna like okay let's let's
have this like morning ritual where we
do the dew and we make the coffee
and very quickly we learned that hand
grinders are not easy
and very quickly we ordered an electric
one
a little trick that i've learned we're
going to add some cinnamon into
our grinding beans it's not only going
to give it like a little kick a little
flavor
but it'll help with your game too with
some antioxidants
well good to know where's this one
helping you on the court too you know
yeah that's up on the corner maybe i
should have known this like
15 years ago we want to pour a little
bit in circular motions
we are opening up that coffee smell that
aroma
it gives a little something something
have you ever tried a coffee neck no
you basically have a cup shut everything
down lights the whole thing
set your alarm for like 20 30 minutes
and essentially
take a nap the benefit you get from the
nap it kind of clears your brain if you
will
and then that's when the caffeine kicks
in so it's like this like
dual boost you get um i've actually been
taking coffee naps for a while whenever
i felt like i needed that and i highly
recommend it i'm gonna try that for sure
next time
midday before my workout perfect and
then we're gonna grab
that flattened umbrella perfect
description
you got your mug my favorite mug it's
like i literally started collecting mugs
when i was traveling overseas away me
too
yeah and it's funny because i have all
kinds of like
funny bugs crazy mugs like geographical
mugs if you will
i played in russia for 10 years i have a
bunch that say rush on it and it's this
one that's my favorite it's just like
plain old mug i don't know i love it
it's getting to a point where we're
actually running out of room
so i've been told i'm not allowed to
purchase anymore
for right now which is fine we have we
have a good collection so
i can work with that i say we take a
little sip we taste it
and then we can chug away
cheers cheers what do you think
really good get your day going for sure
i'm so happy i got to meet you through
coffee habit thank you for your help i
can't wait to impress people i just got
to go
get some equipment and i'll be off and
running you can take that one but that's
all yours awesome even better